play with the chat now they just hold me
back I'm just too good for them
they can't even fathom how much skill I
have inside these meaty hands whoa hello
you're not not my team right into ass oh
boy I see you you jerk wads oh I see
that holy holy hell I'm out here well
that didn't go well seems like maybe we
didn't do something we were supposed to
do like win I'm too high huh Qi I didn't
know it'd go that high you did that in a
low gravity environment that's not my
shotgun I thought I had my shotgun wow I
got that thing you know that thing you
[ __ ] you tree to tree you think you're
gonna give me it's so cold it's so cold
it's so cold I'm gonna die I think I
died here I'm pretty sure this is how I
do if I live through this just remember
I'm awesome and you all are suck but
like my last thing that I say to be an
insult in some way shape or form
who's fighting in here who's a sassy
sack of [ __ ] ah I'm gonna die Vince oh
girl I wish I said some kind of warmth
oh I'm not a [ __ ] baby I'm not a baby
[ __ ] I'm just cold there's a cold old
man who died here and how can I use lag
to my advantage
you you you did I have no name
ah why you get'em just head up head on
well you tried it didn't they're just
hoping they're kicking in thought it's
so stupid so much oh well listen listen
just run don't don't try to help me
don't try to help me dude
Oh Oh God how did I get up here you like
my pistol collection pretty cool right
also I've never used the double-barrel
shotgun
I'm guessing it's real good because I've
been killed by it many a time and I'm
assuming that if I try to use it I'm not
gonna kill anybody I was like chopping
my trees down from the top makes me feel
powerful
you think just cuz you're taller than me
means you're better than me shut up go
to hell this goes super high right in
here oh my god oh my god so far too far
oh hey double barrels of fun come on
hey listen steel
whoa [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you missed me with both of those
can I please oh my god listen that was
embarrassing for both of us but I'd like
to think it was more embarrassing for
you lay in wait in ambush friend killing
those crews I see go for a few joy rides
if you don't mind me [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] I'm gonna complain about it
though like everything else in my life I
reserve the right to complain about it
for as long as I feel is necessary which
is off in a very very long time
sore winner I'm just mad I didn't get a
joyride I'm just a dick win lose just an
[ __ ] I'm not an ass lose body
[ __ ] the boats back on man it's hard to
say in this bush but I've got so much
protection I could never deny it did
they make the bushes boo shear because I
feel like this Boosh is extra boshi all
the air conditioner kicked on no thought
the worst of times
oh when I'm going into the battle zone
oh god it's cold
oh it's just right on my nips why this
gotta be right on my nips
I'll take the credit house it's trying
to help I didn't mean to steal the kill
on you but I'll take it
no shame whatsoever I'm a bouche bag
that's me that's me baby here I come
saving you guys no no I got Bush Kim
foot mark please stop having strokes I
can't help it it's [ __ ] cold why am i
stroking I'm always stroking if there's
one thing that everybody knows about me
it's I'm always stroking all the time no
this is part of the game that just gets
boring it's like if you're the last
person and there's 20 other people on
the team I know you'd love to have that
moment where you just absolutely
annihilate the entire other team but
it's like oh but I just I was wondering
go play the next game any nooks and
crannies to hide in here it's just a big
game of hide and seek
[Music]
okay found you got them not good with
like sniping at a distance what time you
really snipe I guess oh no that's fine
that's fine no you take those two yeah
no that's good yeah no that's all good
please may I have thank you I think
that's nice I think he recognized the
fact that I let him have that thank you
dad now that's good Sports Manchu ale
get a bush now now screw bushes bushes
are for scrubs this is the face of a
scrub I know I was standing there like a
goof please someone mercy
I had to reload stupid idiot pray tell
may someone bequeath me with a
resurrection I'm just gonna hug this
tree listen tree I know you and I had
differences in the past but look I'm a
different man now I'm bigger I'm
stronger and Berthier in a lot of ways
that would surprise you probably oh hey
a fellow tree lover well that's not good
hey listen I've got a nice butt if you
want to give it a squeeze oh well don't
even bother resurrecting me cuz honestly
I just don't even care at this point oh
my God we're gonna die horribly like cuz
we're losing super bad but you're a
sweetie poo is that the same one that
snuck up on me
whoo wait hang on Oh I think that is I
think that's the same one let me see if
I can just get this one
oh no it's the same one oh no you're
watching my stream aren't you I got
sniped that's my problem was I shouted
my intentions at the top of my lungs
turn on stream remote madam it's not
that big a deal
like people make it out to be a much
bigger deal than it actually is
cuz honestly who cares if you're
streaming and playing the game and are
expecting a normal gaming experience
you're just out of your mind you're
playing in front of thousands of people
interviews just happen to be playing in
front of a thousand people in a game
where people could join in then what do
you expect to happen who gives a [ __ ]
that's that's part of the risk of the
deal you can't you can't just go like
damn stream if I catch a stream sniper
I'm still gonna ban them like just cuz I
get personal satisfaction from banning
people like that's just fun for me but
at the same time I'm not gonna wallow in
self-pity and be like my days ruined cuz
someone was watching my stream and
decided to kill me me the super skilled
man that is me they don't go for the
kill they go for the sexiness that makes
more sense see my character is just a
goddamn beacon of sexiness hey wait
is that Wow Wow you want see my dance
pretty good I know right oh you so nice
you so nice are you so nice see it's not
so bad what's the worst thing about
stream snipers they just they can help
and then the crate is mine haha my plan
worked out after all
ho ho ho ho that's so high they're so
high bro pretty nice huh anybody here ah
ah too much lazy snap oh you want a ride
come on I don't know where we're going
and I don't know what we're doing but
we're going for it and we're doing it oh
just from me oh god damn it all right I
guess I'll just be here then stick to
fondling my balls while you take all the
glory oh [ __ ]
right God the circle I keep forgetting
about it I'm like like well I I get so
caught up in like dude this games fun
and then I completely free like oh yeah
there's enough Josh [ __ ]
there I go lotty dog and husband offered
to buy me all the games if I stopped
watching you wait so your husband wants
you to stop watching me and you had a
chance to get every game possible why
are you still watching that seems like a
good deal all the games that has so much
value like all the games there's a lot
about get out of here is that the sound
of like when the portal thing oh [ __ ]
I've saved it saved it totally saved
that I meant to do that and saved it
excuse me I've ordered some ass with
which to kick No
overkill but satisfying each where's the
circle artists like summoned it into
being
hey maybe maybe you want to get one more
let me know I'll help you I can make you
go job I'm gonna swing Marcy sweet
merciful tits I have the greatest
loadout ever but absolutely nothing to
do with it
uh-oh hightail it boys and last one is a
doozy and I'm done see I'm not done
let me end that's it then Oh beautiful
uh I actually liked the hunting rifle
better because I actually don't like to
snipe and the hunting rifle is something
that I can kind of do in between things
so well I don't need to explaining
myself to you I don't need to explain
myself to you at all
I like it therefore that's the end
about [ __ ] I'm not gonna make it ah yes
shockingly [ __ ] [ __ ] get me out there
I'm scared I'm so scared
whoa three health huh have I got any
like you know Keeley's ah a glancing
blow my one weakness oh hey buddy don't
mind as I rule the patient's bump
sneaking up behind you you don't know I
am here I'm gonna shoot you in the back
and then in your rear oh that's problem
hey you guys gonna do something about
that this bad boy bad boy take this bad
boy okay that's an option take this bad
boy all the way up to this bad boy and
then get into the thick of the action
right away because that's how I roll
thick with three C's you don't know how
being a streamer works well it's real
simple you just turn on your camera and
then you act like an idiot for a long
time I'll hop it no go back go back here
let me in let me in I want it so badly
please please I'm like a like a
hang-glider
please oh god please I wanted so
desperately I've never wanted anything
more in my life there we go
right now I would like chill you know
just as a casual thing wait a minute I
think I see shield oh wait no wait I
have shield I'm a dumbass
I got shield what is wrong with me
listen I would save you and I will do I
actually play STW I don't even know what
that is
am I being walked into a lick my balls
joke is this one of those suck my
dongers
that I'm talking about no no no it is TW
sexy train wrecks which is pretty much
an apt description of Who I am
oh hello um listen don't turn around
good job
what's up there Oh - hi god I always
forget
oh god there's only four left it's
always one-sided nothing good matches do
something do something too soon for sure
game over I'm not bad I mean I was able
to get some action there so that was
pretty good
[Music]
you